today we're going to be looking at game
engine called
our machinery that i have never used
before never really seen before so just
check it out
all right okay this is their main page
it's like they have
license available or academic stuff and
let's see what else they got on their
page here early adopters program 50 off
until the end of year 2021 apparently
this is a very new engine a new kind of
game engine
lightweight flexible modular
and extensible okay interesting
yeah we are going to get into it and
install it here shortly
create custom tools and applications and
extend the editor create your own tools
and applications sure most engines can
do this well i know unreal and unity can
but curious to see how they do it real
time collaborative editing cool work in
real time
you're uh whoever you're working on your
game with or whatever made to be hacked
minimalistic code base written in plain
c source code license
available lightweight hackable modern
okay let's watch this little video see
how it goes
from the makers of bits quidditch
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
lately plug and raced
[Music]
[Music]
okay cool
okay so
clearly a lot to learn here
uh let's just
let's just get running and check it out
see what we can do see how it feels so
i've already done this but i'm going to
go over anyway just to have it
documented all right so we hit download
top of the page
it looks like we're going to need an
account let's see how far we can get
before we need to do the account thing
so windows has got a download it is a
zip file so there's no installer
and it looks like it runs on linux it
also looks like
it uses primarily vulkan as the renderer
so that's where i learned about it i was
just looking at game engines i used
vulcan and this was one of them
that i had never really used or seen
before
okay
so it looks like it would run decently
on linux as well
definitely some linux support there and
windows i don't see anything about mac
but it might not be that hard to get it
going on mac if you can get it on linux
because that's the way it tends to be
but i don't know you might have to
translate some of the vulcan stuff to
metal that's that's gonna be messy
okay so we download the windows one
click it you get the download i've
already done this but i'll do it
mostly again or
you can open it uh and you just wanna
extract it i extracted this to where did
i extract this my c drive i think
i extracted it to my source okay so you
basically have to run from this folder
after you extract it no installer i
really should have an installer that
would make a lot more sense but i put it
in here somewhere there it is so i
extracted it right here
and this is the directory you get now
from here i basically had to poke around
until i figured out what to do although
i did
admittedly skip the readme the first
time so let's check that out right now
i guess it's probably the same stuff on
the website
well it doesn't really say much about
getting it going okay
so they've got folders here let's look
at these they've got band code dock
headers live samples utils third-party
code
so
immediately let's just look at the
samples they're using pre-make five and
looks like the sample has a bunch of
plugins including gltf sm
atmospheric sky default render
nodes okay so they've got these all on
the project level that's interesting
simple 3d simple
draw okay
lives here foundation and static okay so
i made some lives with it looks like
with visual studio 2019
there's a bunch of headers
a bunch of add-ons stuff
quite a lot of headers
more than i want to go into so we're
just going to glaze over that uh some
docs
you'll probably have to reference back
to those and looks like this is the code
folder
and they have
source files and dot
but i think we just want to jump right
to the bin and they have a main
application right here they've got all
the dlls
ready to go there's a bunch of little
sub projects here or sub executables
i don't know how these work
or i guess it's probably just other
stuff they've built i guess not entirely
sure
but to
start this i think you just opened this
file here alright there we go
and here is where we need an email and
password so there's no option to
continue
without one
so i'm gonna go make that
on my other screen here
so i think we just gotta go to
where is it i guess it would be
under one of these
okay or we're going to be doing it under
the nd3 for now so we're just testing it
out try before you buy okay download the
machinery create a free account okay so
we'll do all this and i'm gonna do that
on my other screen
and what's a github account make sure
you specify the name of your account all
right sure
put it in there okay
okay
okay got this
all right account created
it's going to confirm my email so i can
do that on my phone
and it appears
i have succeeded
okay
i put this on my other screen okay i
just don't want to reveal my account
name and all that no
i might say it anyway okay
all right we'll just bring it from here
so i sign in looks like first thing you
do is get a
end user agreement
obviously i don't have time to read all
this it's a lot of stuff um
but i agree because what choice do i
have
and here we are we're right in the
engine
interesting it's my first time seeing
this workspace
uh let me get my cam out of the way it's
not gonna be that helpful i'll just make
it really tiny in like the corner here
or up here
i don't know somewhere
maybe right here is fine there we go
okay so let's see if we can like figure
out how to put some basic stuff in here
and work with basic stuff i see we have
a tree over here of uh looks like world
post processing stack
and a sky
there's guy how do i move around okay
right click to move around okay
it feels pretty good and clean so far it
looks like it comes with the sunlight
i think ready to go all right so how do
we add things
i'm just going to try to figure it out
okay we got workspaces over here that
you can just add and let's see how do
you get rid of close
close okay okay we got
some
standard menus file new project save
import new plugin entity component
editor tab simulation entry minimal
let's just click minimal and see what it
gives us
uh
okay these are c files
interesting
and you gotta
let's do a save
see what happens here okay it looks like
it wants us to generate some sort of
save file uh all right i really don't
want it there
so let's make a folder called
looks like once we're in the engine it's
no longer called our machinery it's
called the machinery so that's
interesting
what are we doing we're making or we're
saving
test one
oh wait we just have to select folder
this is like the project folder let's
try this
select folder okay
test one all right
so how do we like add a camera how would
we add scripts how would we actually
start making a world that we could move
around in let's see if we can figure
that out without looking at
documentation okay and here's the
console
looks like it's defaulted to the vulkan
renderer which is cool
i think it's cool anyway i don't know if
other people are going to think that's
cool but it wasn't too bad to get up and
running i'm just gonna go through the
menus and just like see where
everything's at
i don't really know what these buttons
are for is this for adding stuff okay
here's a play button opens the simulate
tab
okay so
rather than popping up a window they
just simulate it right there
there's a picture button what does this
do
it just says default
oh lighting
sliding
default i guess lighting on and off okay
default what there's a box a camera
light plane let's try to put a plane in
how do you
how do you actually add stuff in
okay well we do have an asset browser
here it does come with a box dot entity
but not a whole lot else
and a plane and a sphere okay so let's
like drag these in and see what happens
alright we got a sphere
and we got a box
a play okay
legit
the fov seems weird in this editor i
feel like it's too high but this has
something we can adjust
okay local space gizmos or world space
gizmos i don't know what that means
exactly
i mean i know what the difference
between local and world space is but
what is it actually doing when i'm
clicking this
it's me
so what happens if we hit simulate now
okay we see this we see some boxes so
where's our camera
no idea so what like when we just say
play here what is it
okay it gives us a default flying camera
it looks like without us specifying
anything
okay
we're just flying around in an open
world all right that's not a bad default
but how do we edit all that
okay
so these have a little hierarchy going
on or anything you add
so it's probably best at this point that
i go find like just a basic tutorial
that walks through or the heat even if
even just the documentation so
we're going to go back to the website
and look at learning and support there's
api documentation books videos sample
projects issue trackers and academic
license so let's
start with the api documentation and
just go down through these all right
this is going to be a little dense it
might not be what we want to start with
so maybe books
what do we got here
okay so this is like a web book
they've got an introduction
looks like they've got quite a few
things eventually they get to getting
started which is kind of where we are
first gameplay project sample projects
okay so this is kind of what we want to
start with i think
it says okay add a plane out of box we
figured that out had a camera i did not
figure out how to add a camera make the
box and playing physical so it cannot
make the box in plain physical so the
box cannot fall through
okay so
we're going to use we're going to kind
of follow this not not entirely but okay
so you can change what you're editing
with q w e r
that's cool i like that and let's just
scale okay that's not really what i want
to do scale this wait what is happening
here
oh okay i thought it would scale evenly
maybe i gotta hold a button to make it
scale yeah control
there we go okay so just like a big
ground plane there lowered a little bit
right about there's fine oh that's a
light
okay and
make them physical said how do we do
that
so
do we add component add component
physics
it's got to be one of these
i guess would just be physics body yeah
here we go and we get some mass tensor
enigmatic dampening and disable gravity
okay so on the ground of course we're
going to disable gravity but on like
this thing on the sphere let's
let's go ahead and add component physics
body
i guess we'll leave it default
and let's do the same thing with the
cube over here oh i can't click the key
there we go finally got it
for the box we're calling the box box
cube same thing add a body
wait okay they got gravity
it's got gravity so now what happens if
we hit play they they fall through
they fall through the things so how do
we make them not fall through a
kinematic means it's driven by animation
rather than true physics that's okay how
do we ccd
continuous collision detection okay i
guess we add those and hit play let's
see if that does it no
they still fall through okay so we stop
the simulation by hitting the pause or
no i guess we just close it
okay
how do we they said make the boxing
plane physical so the box cannot fall
through how do you make it physical
okay yeah we've been there
okay they have
more properties okay let's see what we
got here hey i'm not seeing it
so on the box
they've added a physics body and a
physics shape and on the plane they've
added a physics shape okay so physics
the plane we don't want a body let's
delete that we want a shape physics
shape oh whoa that looks
not right
type plane
can i j how do you just auto match it
oh i guess we do convex
or uh
no it's so weird that it doesn't just
figure out what it is for the plane you
would think that it would do okay that's
not what we want to do
so do we have to manually put all this
in here okay there's no dragging on
these numbers so we'll have to type them
every time that's kind of annoying let's
rotate it 90 i'll need no it's happening
here
okay i like that you can just okay so
you hold right click fly around in the
editor that's kind of cool how do we
flip this around then
okay so they scaled it 10 10 10 that's
just the transform so let's like copy
what they're doing n
10 10 okay
that means we should be able to copy
their physics thing as well what do they
got for physics shape
they have
a box with a half extend okay well
that's the box
play plane radius one
okay plane this must be an older version
because i don't have a radius
for plane i have scale
position and all that okay we'll see if
this works
and and
i guess it's working
i don't know all right let's see if we
can get this
keep going so we want a body and a shape
all right so let's add a shape to this
thing add component
physics shape
oh it
so weird oh what what is going on here
um
that doesn't look right
what is oh that's is that the camera oh
it's part of the physics shape why is
this all the way over here i'm so
confused
this is a plain physics shape this is
what it looks like well i think i kind
of see what they're going for but it's
very
very confusing
because i've clicked shape i feel like i
should be able to rotate it but this
rotates everything the plane
i guess if i want to rotate just the
shape i gotta
do it here i don't think this is right
so what why is the scale so huge
when the plane is not even
close to that big where did everything
else so it's really small all right so
now let's click
i'm really confused by this whole thing
to be honest all right so they have set
okay well that was pretty interesting
it's all the time i got this morning but
got her feet wet
it seems like the documentation is a
little behind the latest development
that's kind of what i'm observing here
so i'm trying to just
just add this
these colliders which it lets me do but
like how do i just rotate it to match
and why can't it just do it
automatically that's what's kind of
throwing me for a loop here and what
and it looks like when i added the
sphere originally oh my god this thing
just slow down slow down camera
okay did i does that go in the right
place it's actually on top of the sphere
yeah it is
i don't know let's just hit play one
last time here or log up
falls through again
all right
well that's all i got time for today
wait what are these are they still
falling
or do they stop
they're just floating
all right well this simulation stuff is
going to take a little getting used to
with this engine because i have no idea
what is actually going on and what i
need to really change to get it to work
as expected
but uh pretty cool though i really like
the interface interface is nice it
actually feels pretty good the way you
add components to things
i'd be curious to see how it handled my
own models or just models from random
sources like this chicken
that's not what i meant to do this
chicken see what happens i just drag it
and drag it in nothing
if i drag it into our geometry then i
bring it in
there we go got our chicken
doesn't have the textures right and it's
flipping massive
but it's but it's there okay all right
well thanks for watching
see you guys next time
peace
final thoughts on our machinery
uh nice try nice try should anyone buy a
license in my experience no
but it's getting there maybe in another
few months or after a few more updates
but just based on the fact
that the most simple version of adding
physics to objects like didn't even work
right and i couldn't seem to get it to
work right kind of
like told the whole story so other than
that
it was fine but you know i didn't get
much further because i basically got
stuck there so i think that's going to
happen in general to any person they're
going to get stuck on every little thing
because it's going to be weird and buggy
well i don't really know for sure but
that's the impression i got so yeah i
don't think it's worth at this current
time i hope they make updates i hope to
see them do well but uh
yeah that's the impression i got all
right thanks for watching consider
supporting me
[Music]
i love making videos but as you guys may
have noticed it's really not worth my
time or anyone's time if with this
at this level as like a youtuber
youtuber
so uh consider joining via the join
button on youtube or on patreon it's
three bucks a month it's not very much
and uh if you could afford it um it
would go a long way towards helping me
keep these productions going and making
them better in the meantime
they've got to be minimalistic because i
cannot put so much effort into him as i
have been as i said in the last video
alright peace out guys
[Music]